hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
thriller science fiction and the most
unsettling series from black mirror
seasons two called white bear this movie
has an unpredictable plot twist watch it
till the end to find out
the movie starts with a woman waking up
in pain in a dark room with both of her
wrists wrapped up in bandages
she sees pills scattered on the floor
and tv displaying a symbol
the woman then goes downstairs she sees
a marked calendar and a photo of her
family attached with a portrait of a kid
in the frame
as she takes the portrait of the girl
she gets flashbacks from her memory
turns out she lost her memory after she
woke up
the woman goes out from her house and
sees many people using their phone to
film her
she starts to scream and asks for help
but she gets ignored
suddenly a masked man comes to her and
starts to point a shotgun at her the
woman gets panicked and then she runs
from the masked man
the masked man then chases the woman
along with those people who film her as
the woman runs she meets and asks for
help from a man and a young woman that
doesn't hold a phone to film her they
run to hide inside a store
after a while the masked man arrives at
their location and starts to break the
glass window at the same time the young
woman is trying to open the back door
after the masked man manages to break
the glass he enters the store and
immediately gets detained by the other
man
both of the women manage to get out
after the back door is open leaving the
place behind
the other man gets shot by the masked
man and badly injured as they leave the
place they meet another masked man going
to the store they run and hide inside a
house
the young woman explains to the woman
that the masked man is called the hunter
and the people who film are called
onlookers
she also says that onlookers are people
affected by the symbol displayed on the
tv
she calls it the signal
the young woman also says that they need
to get to white bear the place that
transmits the signal when hearing the
word of white bear the woman starts to
get flashbacks from her memory again
she finds out that the girl in the
picture is her daughter
the woman tries to chase away the
onlookers around them but then they are
spotted by the hunter while they try to
run suddenly an old man driving a van
stops by and asks them to get in after
they get away the woman with a confused
face says that she knows the old man but
he said that he doesn't know her then
the young woman asks the old man to
drive them to white bear but he refuses
because he says it's not safe
he says that the only safe place for
them is the woods and he'll take them to
the woods
after they arrive suddenly the old man
pulls out a shotgun and points it at
them turns out the old man is the masked
man from before
he forces the woman to put on the
balaclava and then takes them to the
hunters would spot the old man calls the
other hunter and while on the call the
young woman manages to sneak out and
leaves them behind
the old man doesn't has time chase the
young woman and prepares to torture the
woman the young woman then sneaks back
and takes the shotgun to shoot the old
man
after that they take the van and leave
the woods
while on the way to white bear the woman
tells the young woman that she starts to
remember things the name of her daughter
jemima and her husband has a tattoo the
same as the symbol displayed on the tv
the young woman ignores her and then
rushes to go inside white bear
they get inside the transmitter room and
the young woman starts to pour oil all
over the room
suddenly the hunters come and attack
them
while the hunter focuses on the young
woman the woman takes the shotgun from
one of the hunters she shoots the hunter
but turns out the shotgun is a party
popper
suddenly the wall moves and a lot of
people give applause to them the hunter
locks the woman in a chair and suddenly
the old man from before appears on the
stage as the emcee
the old man says that the man from the
picture was her fiance ian rannick then
the old man shows who the woman really
is by using news the woman victoria
skilling abducted a girl named jemima
sykes jemima's body is found in a local
forest along with her white teddy bear
jemima's body was found wrapped in a
sleeping bag and burnt
ian tortured and murdered jemima while
skilling held the camera to film it
skilling cries so hard and begs for help
but the audience starts booing her then
she is paraded through the street and
returned to the same room she awoke at
the beginning of the movie she is placed
in the same position as before and also
all the items that she takes the old man
places a headphone shaped device on her
head to erase her memory after that the
old man marked the calendar on the
current date meaning that they have done
this multiple times at the movie's end
screen it's revealed that the place is
an amusement park named white bear
justice park the crew take the role as
the hunters and the visitors take the
role as onlookers
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching